yes
[Music]
go
who's the head honcho around here hi
how are you oh sir my name is steven
crowder and these here are the uh uh mug
club z's from lighter earth crowder late
night comedy of salvation of south of
seoul and we hear you might have a
platform for us to upload our videos to
well that all depends
you boys do conservative videos
uh sir we we we are a cub uh let's all
accept our cumber our company uh all
except our half asian lawyer standing in
the corner over there
well i really don't do conservative
videos
i'm looking for more sjw socialist
material well we just started featuring
five young terp videos every day the
platform and everybody else so thanks
for stopping by
sir mud club and lot of cried have been
steeped in socialism heck you're silly
with it ain't disease
that's right we ain't really
conservatives i'll accept that half
asian lawyer stand in the corner over
there
[Music]
[Music]
i've
been shadow
demonetized
notifications won't work for days
notifications
won't work for days
for
three long
years i've been in trouble
shadow band
[Music]
classified
[Music]
then
i hired a
man who was half asian
he practiced law
that's what they say
now
he sticks it to
those big [ __ ]
[Music]
he
[Music]
and demonetized
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
that's the sound of monday that's the
asmr monday it's monday sounds like
someone's got a case for the mondays
oh stop it i know it's disgusting can
you believe some people are into that i
don't know that they do the chewing part
i don't know i assume they're german
okay we have a lot to get to uh and i
know he's not germany south africa but
he has one of those weird accents
elon musk
what is easy jeremy is you know i i
don't know i don't buy it but uh he's
now the largest stakeholder in twitter
really that's a big change so people are
mad about it which is funny to me you
would think that the the woke you know
leftist would be thrilled that the
person who basically spearheaded the
modern electric car movement
is now in charge of one of the biggest
tech platforms and or not in charge but
has the biggest say well
but no
they had to boot them from california
yeah yeah if you can't make green
policies work in california how can you
make it work also uh the grammys i don't
know if you know this apparently uh
louis c.k winning the award that's an
example of cis white men will debunk
that and more importantly the southern
border everyone's talking about russia
and ukraine and uh
look we've talked about that we feel
like we've mined that as much as we can
no one's talking about what's going on
in the south southern when i say no one
i mean very few so hold your comments
there
not nobody ever but it's not being
discussed with the same level of
intensity as what's happening uh halfway
i mean halfway really completely across
the globe but halfway is the longest
point that's that's sort of like when
someone says he did a 360 well then he
did he didn't change anything he's doing
the same thing you mean he did a 180
just looked like an idiot yeah exactly
you just did a 360. it's like that's
just a trick
so uh it's a problem and we're looking
at a record number of illegal immigrants
will be coming into this country and of
course you know it'll be nice that these
people can vote
that's part of the big plan you don't
need to believe in a conspiracy to
understand the great reset you just need
to observe
what's happening around you so my
question before any of that to you
question of the day helps with the
youtube algorithm is if you could choose
any country
uh to which you would illegally
immigrate which would it be
[Music]
you can't say the united states
and if you say canada you'll be doxxed
so
i think going to canada does punishment
enough yes exactly
if we lived in canada we'd punish
ourselves name that movie line all right
gerald a he already spoke up he's here
you know him how are you sir i am well
how are you i'm doing i still have a
neck injury but you know what's oh
really yeah did you look up too quickly
i did look that's exactly what happened
you know when you get that is exactly
what happened
yes
when you get past a certain age that's
all it takes and you never want to
describe that you're like yeah somebody
punched me
no what happened was i was in the gym
doing uh deadlifts and i heard a sound
in the gym and it was this someone went
and so
like that was it
that was the batman turn yeah otherwise
there's only two ways that you hurt your
neck uh and you guys can comment below
you know what those two ways are if you
watch curb your enthusiasm and we also
have here you know him you love him him
and i will be uh we're on tour but
specifically may 14th in tulsa oklahoma
the tulsa ballroom um there's some
tickets left there you can go to the
lottery with credit.com tour to see all
the other dates but a lot of them are
sold out check your town but tulsa
oklahoma may 14th
is a big ass room we're looking forward
to it uh atlanta dave how are you sir
i'm good ahoy friend how are you i'm
fine what's that on your shirt it's an
elephant oh cause an elephant never
forgets a friend oh they also never
forget uh abuse yeah no they don't they
they i i own a circus where i hurt them
yes yeah exactly they do tricks yeah i
also have a i also have a bearded lady
who i have hooked on the opium yep she
enjoys it she will do anything for one
of those droppers okay more of a
tincture really i'm a i'm a uh i'm an
apothecarist
yes i'm a drug dealer
yeah i just call it apothecary i give
freaks drugs yeah exactly basically what
i do that's what they want so before i
move on to everything uh parents did
them
no so how have you seen his parents he
doesn't he doesn't look like them oh no
no they were taking steroids
absolutely
yeah they come up to about here he's are
you serious he's a christian he's a very
tall crack baby yeah what they're
definitely my parents but i like that
they have a weird genetic profile where
they actually uh crack made him grow
larger and stronger good for you love
parmesan yeah and drywall okay before we
get to all of that ain't chips uh snl
returned
to full cringe this time uh they were
this is also how you know like snl has
decided this is something that's kind of
important you look at it culturally at
one point you know you have carson right
where 50 50 million people would tune in
there was a sort of centralized uh focal
point of the country where you had
things that would be referenceable
because everyone was reading the same
newspapers watching the same news so
okay
this is the material that's broad enough
to work with snl now they've decided to
go leftist politic uh niche because
they're doing a sketch mocking clarence
thomas of course justice clarence thomas
for having been in the hospital and his
wife in january 6 with their they're
desperately trying to make a thing
unless you read the liberal blogs or
watch god forbid cnn or msnbc it's
probably not a story that you're
following so that tips snl's hand as to
where they're leaning now and to whom
they're catering here is the sketch dave
has not watched it yet because i didn't
want to subject him to it twice
clarence thomas on snl okay guys
speaking of truths all right crush of
the week ted cruz absolutely wiped the
floor with katanji brown jackson last
week by waving a children's book at her
so powerful fatality i'm sorry miss
jessica supposedly brian kill me the
first amendment not sure
they nailed the set and nothing else
honorable justice thomas you were just
in the hospital is that
right what they say
keenan thompson's always funny yeah
what's going on you feeling all right
i guess we'll see hello mr president are
you on facetime if you build it i will
come hello friends can you see me
mr president wow what a treat thanks for
fitting us into your busy schedule now
sir the january 6 committee that is a
great trouble to make all sorts of
claims so let's just put this to rest
did you commit a coup you know he's not
the president right you know what there
was no coup it was an event perhaps a
take back event a coup perhaps
but uh i don't like ku i just don't like
who i don't like the p at the end of ku
i think you should take that p and push
it
p
um
of course if you take off p from coup
you have cow which goes mu
which
you know perhaps that's where they get
coup but dooku who do you do do what
remind me of the babe but yes i
appreciate the labyrinth reference yeah
that's not bad it was an intentional
planned coup yes
now here's the thing take away all the
money meaning the set and the makeup the
guy does a great trump voice he does you
know he doesn't really voice works look
a ton like trump that's where they have
the makeup that comes into play all the
makeup still doesn't make them look
anything like the fox and friends hosts
take away the budget and you end up with
you know distill it down to the writing
does the cia actually write the sketch
or do they just give them pointers yeah
well they show up oh i see and they
claim that they're just teenage fans oh
i got you and snl looks at their demo
like we don't have any teenage fans
steve buscemi with the skateboards hello
fellow kids hey what's up
so they were trying to obviously go
after clarence thomas almost a
conservative supreme court justice
trying to embarrass him but i guess you
know what they couldn't uh they couldn't
make clarence thomas uh as uncomfortable
as a former vice president joe biden did
at the hearings legislators in defeating
the nunes plan in the basement said
quote we already have a [ __ ] mayor we
don't need any more [ __ ] big shots
well he can say it because he has a
dementia pass that's the real president
yes yeah that's the one who's in office
can we play it again he's balder then
yeah then he is now looking through the
legislators in defeating the nunes plan
in the basement said quote we already
have a [ __ ] mirror we don't need any
more [ __ ] big shots so geez first of
all we wanted to get back in the black
pool yes exactly
your hair typically regrows once it gets
gray so no no i was bald until my gray
hair grew in don't stick the r even when
you're quoting joe what an idiot
i also that just tells you how it's like
steven seagal where he thinks that we
don't know that he's using the spray
paint from the old you know infomercial
late at night he's like no i've never
used hair plugs this is my we saw you
when you were 25 and you were going
balls right and now you have the bella
lugosi perfect triangular widow's peak
we don't buy it like joe biden thinks
that people just say oh yeah that's his
normal hair he was bald at 40 and now he
has a full head of gray hair yeah you
and movie vampires yes even though in
your first movie you don't have that
right exactly
you just don't get to do it if you're in
the public eye you either have to start
the plugs from the get-go so it's
believable or you just have to go with
the bald look you have to go with the mr
freeze look you don't have the option of
then just coming out one day like no no
look i have a full hair totally normal
yeah the more the fatter steven seagull
gets the more uh like karate uniforms he
wears yeah notice that yes like he just
wears them as robes yes like that's what
we're not gonna notice yeah just a moo
moo with a chinese collar yeah exactly
yeah i've become more yes asian yeah now
he has his russian passport you see he
has russian citizenship oh lord
he's just an absolute you know he's
stephen
i mean he's amazing yes he's a yeah he's
amazing he's teaching them how to run
yes exactly i think he's a stacking doll
of himself yes why's in russia
yes there's just different phases of
steven seagal's career inside of him
this is hard to kill here's half past
dead that's hard to kill there's under
siege too yeah here's me 400 pounds
playing a fender all sweaty at a bar yes
there's me as a cop in the new orleans
okay uh was me wheezing against a van
just now yes
here's the van tipping over
now uh it's a high center of gravity was
more of an suv van now let's move on to
elon musk
wearing sunglasses all the time
they're more hunting glasses yes that's
why they're yellow tactical so uh as of
this morning elon musk has reportedly
acquired a 9.2 percent stake in twitter
boom that makes him the largest
individual shareholder of the company uh
surpassing vanguard and blackrock which
i love yes i love them not a fan of
vanguard and black rock hey have you and
i want you to comment i was just talking
about this uh when i was taking the
twins for a walk with my parents this
this weekend and we were walking through
a neighborhood uh and there's some
businesses in like that area where
there's shops and restaurants yeah and i
was have you ever experienced in your
lifetime home prices that are soaring
right you can't buy can't buy a house
but then you go down the main streets
all the businesses are closed that's
where you know there's this weird
disconnect because it's not people
buying the homes it's these giant
corporations right who want to create a
permanent class of renters i remember
when we had you know for example the
recession that had taken place in 2009.
well what happened there were a bunch of
foreclosures there were a bunch of empty
houses there were also a bunch of empty
businesses yeah or then when it came
back you know you had donald trump you
had home prices going up but you had
record low unemployment you had
businesses that were flourishing this is
the first time i can remember ever
in my 30 plus years on this earth
home price is soaring that market is is
something you can't even catch up with
it's just absolutely ablaze and then uh
more businesses i should say a good
portion more than i've ever seen in my
lifetime completely shut down there was
a strip mall area there used to be a
donut shop a cleaners uh a jewelry
repair yeah all three of them closed
it's a really really weird dynamic
mm-hmm
we'll try bidding on a house now yeah i
know you have somebody come in who's
actually part of an investment group
pretending that they're not yeah and
they're going to outbid you by 50 grand
on a house that's 300. it's insane yeah
yeah it really is crazy because the
people aren't the ones who are able to
buy these houses well no and nobody's
gonna who's gonna put that kind of money
into a house right nobody and then
people [ __ ] about redlining it's like
you have any idea the kind of monster
you're creating oh that's right they're
too big to fails at elizabeth warren so
my point is elon musk more shares in
blackrock i love it
and it doesn't mean that i'm entirely
sold on elon musk uh the shares of the
company went up 26 percent yeah with dr
musk's purchase yeah the announcement
was made today this happened a few weeks
ago but he had to disclose it right uh
and he made a billion dollars
so on paper well yeah all he has to do
is sell it if he chooses to get out of
it but a billion dollars not so bad on
profit in what two and a half weeks yeah
that works out well no it works
and here's what i i do like to see um he
tweeted out a couple of things people
are focusing on him sort of doing an end
zone dance but this is what i think is
most telling uh he tweeted out given
that twitter serves at the de facto
public town square failing to adhere to
free speech principles fundamentally
undermines democracy
what should be done that's not just a
you know you see grifters who sometimes
say oh i'll appeal to the right and you
have these people on the left who say
it's way easier to make money appealing
to the right really snl abc nbc cbs
msnbc right just everybody the fact is
there's fox news does well and so do
programs like this because they're what
an alternative alternatives tend to do
well with an alternative audience but
it's an alternative to what
everything in the mainstream that being
said there are some grifters out there
who aren't necessarily genuine and they
do see some kind of an economic
opportunity this isn't that this seems
to be a guy who understands genuinely
that nothing changes uh outside of
removing the safe harbor rules with
section 230. yeah the arguments that
we've been making for a long time the
arguments that i can't fully discuss
things that have been going on behind
the scenes as it relates to this but
that is something that i'm happy to see
the largest stakeholder in twitter
saying hey we can't keep doing this if
we're the town square that's leaked
that's important legalese there yeah
absolutely we've been making that town
square point for a while and remember
this is the guy that founded x.com that
ended up merging and ended up going into
paypal and their whole purpose was to go
against centralized banks and give
people more freedom right this isn't new
for elon yeah this is something that
then paypal decided to start banning
conservatives well they he sold out of
it right so this is consistently what
he's been doing so i hope he takes that
same stance here and somebody's going to
say oh it's only 9.2 9.3 do you
understand what happens when the largest
shareholder walks in to a major
corporation like this and says i want to
meet with the ceo right do you want a
carl icon coming in and totally changing
everything he basically walks in i would
like to meet with the ceo and um
there's my penis
yeah i believe it is the largest in the
room yes
it is 9.2 larger
roughly 1.2 percent more than any of you
have yeah also i have flamethrower does
anyone want to uh argue
no okay don't wait up
yeah he owns almost 10 percent of
twitter that's a lot yeah that is a lot
i'm really glad to see it and i hope
look i hope we see some changes this is
this is one thing that republicans
screwed up they had power donald trump
did not do enough and you can see right
now democrats are running as quickly as
possible to try and get more control you
saw it with jen saki calling for more
censorship you see it with the hearings
that take place very very different tone
from unfortunately it was nothing but
hearings with mark zuckerberg it was
nothing but hearings with people from
youtube republicans didn't do a whole
lot but now liberals are trying to enact
legislation i hope that they i don't
think they will be able to to try and
gain more control over social media so
if someone in the billionaire class
decides to wield that power against
these uh
these uh evil i won't say of course uh
uh you know pedophile satanic ring
that's not true i will just say um evil
um people
pieces of [ __ ] yeah that's fair that's
fair yeah it's more of a it's more
conjecture yes you don't need to fact
check it it's an opinion it's an opinion
really yeah my opinion is that they are
equivalent to human pieces
of [ __ ] it's an opinion based on the
fact that they are yeah right also
striking similarities yes yes yeah now
look spirit cooking
did i say that out loud
i don't know what that is is that what
alec baldwin's wife does with her feet
as she
with her fake spanish accent
i am going to cook the spirit i put in
the peppers because they're hot where
are the hot peppers damn it i put in the
peppers
i'm gonna get my gun yes don't worry
it's nothing but planks and i don't know
how to pull the trigger then how did you
shoot the lady
it was stephen baldwin yes
is that another bald one no you always
blame us stephen baldwin the lesser
baldwin is you
is billy not billy borwin this billy who
used to be william
so now uh
because he's not likable not your
billionaire you're always unlikable
don't get me started on daniel he looks
like you but too fat he's very fast they
all look the same i just have to go by
the fatness the chart of fatness and
then a little bit maybe who's stupid
with stephen baldwin he looks like he's
not too smart in the face do you know
the eyes the anger chart you are on top
honey yes you're in top of the in your
church you punch the reporter you punch
your wife you yell at your daughter
[Music]
you kill the lady
you're very mad yeah he's a bad person
here's me here's your foot dinner
so of course the liberal crowd is upset
with elon musk uh now he has a huge
influence on twitter and i will say this
he's been taking some risks i don't know
if you saw his meme about john lennon
can we bring that up
where it's him saying imagine no
possessions nothing to uh you know uh
kill or die for and then he gets shot
now i did a video on this in 2009 about
john lennon and i think he got removed
from youtube this is something i always
thought was just i mean imagine no
possessions you mean like three rolls
royces and a penthouse in the upper west
side right yeah yeah exactly uh but uh
also nothing to live nothing to kill or
die for means nothing to live for i
don't know i hate that song i hate
everything about it
i hate that it plays i also hate a
stupid christmas song
i don't care for much of what he did at
all no that offends you because it's
christmas and you can't screw with chris
especially the fact that he's john
lennon and he just dated somebody with
no ass yeah well the good news is he
cheated on her while in between beatings
of his son well that's true he was a
good man yeah he was a good man that
john lennon
he wore the harry potter glasses ahead
of his time yes
he hurt kids yep
ahead of his time as well apparently
yeah that's true so it'll be interesting
to see what happens with musk and
twitter my guess is he'll try and find a
way to force him out
there's going to be a lot of pressure
behind the scenes i i hope i hope i hope
he puts tons of pressure and if they
force him out fine if he sells the stock
price craters again and he's gonna start
his own thing yeah i hope that is the
result uh yes i bought nine point five
percent of twitter and uh today uh i
killed mark zuckerberg so that's mine
now that's the deal yeah why is it i ran
him over with my tesla he never heard me
coming nope
he's very quiet car for killing it's a
very good killing car very good sneak up
i first designed it this car for killing
and then it caught on and i was like
okay let's go with it so uh 187 engine
yes a 187 engine
um all right gen saki this is something
that people were talking about but we do
have some exclusive uh news broke of
course last week that the white house
press secretary yeah jen saki uh be
stepping down to take a job at msnbc
so you know let it when people say oh
it's just you right-wing conspiracy
theorists that the media is left
i mean you know about look at george pop
it out whatever stephanopoulos you know
this guy worked for the clintons right
we've created all of these we've shown
you all these connections in the past
between
but now you're seeing it in real time
and i know you'll say well kaylee mack i
went to fox news yes that's one person
again one person to one outlet if you go
through msnbc abc news cbs cnn you will
find through producers through executive
producers on air talent unashamedly
plenty of people like jinsaki yeah and
she went to one of the most left places
possible to go to that has a station
yeah exactly yeah chose the quote
unquote middle the middle-of-the-road
lefty site
to the loosest sense of the world yes i
hope she just goes to msnbc and just
hammers behind the scenes so lawrence
o'donnell is like
i don't know why i didn't know this but
i didn't realize msnbc until last week
was microsoft nbc yeah i was like oh
that's terrifying yes exactly i just
never even bothered looking up what that
meant soon to be majority shareholder
microsoft in vaccine technology yes
right right that's a longer name yeah it
didn't fit in so well yeah pfizer bc
yeah pfizer biotech bs
uh
j nbc msn yes
so actually she resigned and of course
uh now we have uh this came uh recently
we have a clip of her uh resignation oh
it's actually on is it oh she's actually
talking right now oh oh clifford
fox on capitol hill oh her resignation
she's doing it right now she's
officially talking yeah
this is cnn breaking news
[Music]
i'll be back i always come back
[Music]
oh
well yeah she's coming back yeah i guess
well i guess she's not gonna be gone
that long now here's the thing there
hasn't been an official replacement
announced
okay because a lot of people are asking
us what you know we get the scoop
sometimes um but they have found an
interim replacement sort of a
a temp okay a substitute replacement um
and i guess this is based maybe on the
recent jessie waters interview but it's
again this is just a placeholder it's
not permanent uh we have some footage of
the replacement for gensake uh in action
at a recent conference
what is the us's general position on
potential future attacks by ukraine on
russian soil does the u.s believe that
it is up to the ukrainians to decide
whether such potential attacks are
justified or does it generally believe
um that those kinds of attacks should be
discouraged because they would be seen
as being escalatory you look like a big
[ __ ] on heat and if you get raped by a
pack of numbers it'll be your fault all
right
whoa
that's just another reason to question
this administration's judgment i hope
they're on a trial period yeah well yeah
i don't think it's permanent i don't
think so something in the claws yeah
he's a little too blunt by the way don't
expect him to honor that mutual uh
non-dis that non-disclosure agreement
nope i mean she shouldn't be wearing
that no she shouldn't
just making eyes at him and he knew it
now
louis ck
uh
louis ck won a grammy nice nice for a
comedy album yes yeah and um
regardless of where you line up on louis
ck i'm going to give you a couple of
examples here uh well first off let me
ask you do you think this is a problem
louis ck winning a grammy i want you
guys to comment below joe lewis stop it
go to your place
yeah by the way joe lewis forces us
to watch exactly what louis c.k did in
the green room every day every day every
single he didn't even ask there's just
no complaints
at all well
louis ck only was using his mouth no
exactly well he just you know he wasn't
flexible enough no joe lewis
yoga private really eventually paid off
i i think i think that look it's
obviously what louis c.k did is weird
but it's not nearly the same when we
just this is one remember me too was a
thing where we care about women but now
it's you know men can compete we don't
care about me too anymore because we
have men competing with women in sports
who are still attracted to women
changing in their locker rooms with
raging erections like via thomas that's
fine though it's a female erection the
tape fails it's a vascular throbbing
female erection yes how are you gonna
have to fall to a doctor like oh well i
thought i was testing a female
unfortunately you have a
a boner that's a that's a female boner
oh let me just write that in my chart
sorry let me put that medical discovery
let me put that in my pretend chart for
your pretend life yes exactly
also all the voices uh in your head i'll
give them names why not yes let's go for
that one will be harold and lyle i don't
know what am i speaking to now yeah eric
and lyla
so louis ck want a grammy okay which is
fine yes absolutely it should be fine
when you think about the fact that he's
an unbelievable comedian it was just for
the quality of his art of course the
left is taken to twitter the left has
taken to the media
and i don't want to spend too much time
on their claims because they're very
easily debunked yes but really art for a
long time is one of the few areas that's
a meritocracy and let's be honest it's
not like artists have a great track
record of being upstanding human beings
come on no louis ck is really you know
is the least offensive amongst them
but not to people on twitter why because
he's a white male i'll get to it so usa
today editor barbara vanderburgh he's
also hispanic yeah i know he's mexican
he's actually mexican
will smith is going to end up more
punished than louis ck you watch well i
hope so journalist david perry uh who
apparently may have blocked me i don't
know said i just want to say that every
single person who decides to continue
participating in the grammys and yes
that includes your favorite is complicit
in normalizing sexual abuse nope what
roswell showrunner karina mckenzie
tweeted out louis ck just won a grammy
in case you were still crying about
cancel culture yep
dr mia brett oh well here's a doctor
uh wrote louis c.k just won a whole ass
grammy while y'all are how would you
love it if your doctor sounded like that
yeah like your knee is swol your knee is
ass swollen y'all man your heart stopped
beating when i was operating on your dad
your heart is his heart was his heart
was swollen [ __ ] is this an honorary
thing like dr dre
his heart was like shook night up and
that's my okay so i'm gonna write you
some percocet
more like dr pepper yep
dr seuss
[Laughter]
i'll go another direction let's give him
another injection i've had nine mrna
vaccines yeah i don't know why dr seuss
is black
maybe whatever you know doesn't matter
there's a glocket in my pocket okay
louis ck
just won a whole ass grammy while y'all
are either calling for will smith's head
or crying about cancer culture there are
no consequences for white
and in parentheses cis het men i didn't
realize what heck meant hetero it means
heterosexual yeah yeah yeah yeah which
is just interesting to me because uh i
thought cis was all encompassing but
even they can't stick with their own
standards so a couple things that are
inaccurate here uh he's not white right
he's not white start there he's he's
mexican he's a mexican man yeah huh
that's why he also calls his name ck
because it is the phonetic way to say
his name right because nobody could get
it right right so he's helpful as well
also as far as cancel culture people you
know he had his the film i love you
daddy was immediately removed from its
release date okay by distributors dumped
by his agency manager publicist he lost
35 million dollars in an hour he was
persona non grata for about five years
where he wasn't able to be booked yet he
built his way back up honestly in small
clubs and created good material that
culminated in this album which by the
way is pretty damn good yes and also the
special that goes along with it with
just the word sorry behind him is
hilarious yes exactly
but here's the thing they're trying to
say oh cancel cultures well there you go
okay cancel culture is obviously real
and if you don't want to support louis
ck that's fine my issue is not if you
choose to boycott or bycot somebody my
issue is when it's not actual market
forces determining the level of offense
but a bunch of celebrities who decide to
exert pressure just like we've talked
about with comedy clubs people used to
say that comedy clubs were the last
bastion of free and i and i would get
into it even like nick depaulo with
other comedians that say look you don't
understand it's you're doing well
because you can draw a crowd the guy at
the open mic who's making a joke about
leah thomas and the club booker doesn't
want to take that heat he's just not
going to take that risk that's the
problem with this idea of cultural
censorship it's not cancelled culture
it's cultural censorship because these
people will actually make calls to try
and make to try and enforce their ideals
to the point that you can't make a
living okay let's stop using the term
cancel culture it's taking food from
your family's mouth because you disagree
with the pre-approved opinion and even
then they can't get their premise
correct because they said white guy
about a mexican
well that's how they have to push it
though because they know right that's
what bothers me the most they know and
they still stick with misinformation to
try to trick everybody and the worst
part is if you want to watch louis ck
you should be able to right stop calling
a club stop protesting stop doing all
that i mean you're allowed to but it's
annoying after years and years and years
that once you're being told that
everything you say is false right
including what those women said yes
exactly you have janine garofalo you
have sarah silverman you have all these
people that have come forward those
women didn't get a career out of
something 20 years later that's the fact
right he just asked them if they wanted
to see his wiener and they were like i
guess and yeah it's weird but you know
what it was this thing it was actually
consensual a yes yeah bottom line it was
a yes and then people said well it
wasn't consensual because the dynamics
of power yeah okay you're comparing it
to will smith will smith just committed
felony battery against a man on say you
want to talk about white privilege will
smith just committed the kind of violent
assault that if he was anybody else on
planet earth would be behind bars if not
at least shoved around by security and
said he sat down nothing happened and
then he accepted his academy award later
to thunderous applause
consequence-free really you want to say
do you think will smith is going to go
five years without working so even using
your example it's stupid and i don't
mean yo stupid like good i mean
unintelligent let me give you a few
other examples while you talk about
louis c.k winning a grammy chuck berry
remember him by the way wrote most of
the early beatles songs arrested in 1959
for transporting a 14 year old girl
across state lines for quote immoral
purposes what does that mean he won the
lifetime achievement award in 1984. well
also let's mention uh put cameras in all
of his restaurant bathrooms yes
as well so he's the guy that made the
rule now that you can't do that that was
his role and also yeah marty mcfly did
steal rock and roll from him though yes
he did so you know that wasn't fair puff
daddy was arrested for assault deadly
weapon 2015 nominated for his fourth
grammy in 2016. dr dre pled guilty to
battery of a police officer 92 police
officer 92. he won his grammy in 94.
a police
stop drinking on the floor you gotta
stop going by with them construction
workers at 3 p.m getting tekate and [ __ ]
this
[Laughter]
come on you see you got the heroes you
see it in racetrack and quick drift it's
just it's just like it might as well
just be the actual factory line of
takate yes going down
so he won a grammy 1994 for best rap
solo performance r kelly sex tape
underage that began circulating in 2002
he's been nominated 15 times since what
15 times since did we know about this
yes it was circulating was there a dave
chappelle sketch about this in oh three
almost like there could have been
letting it happen but he's been canceled
too because he can't have someone tell
the truth
see the danger when you cancel people
for telling the truth just because you
don't like it then no one listens to
them it's the opposite of the boy who
cried wolf it's a boy who's not crying
wolf it's a boy who's actually telling
you that there's a wolf there only he's
always telling the truth and you only
allow him to speak when there is no wolf
for example if he says i'm going to
affirm all genders now bruno mars was
arrested for cocaine possession 2010 he
won the record of the year best r b
performance lil wayne arrested in 2007
on criminal possession loaded weapon
best rap performance 2017 and the most
egregious example being chris brown
chris brown a black man
committed felony assault and battery
against rihanna a black woman
and he is being nominated for the album
of the year twice this year he was
nominated 12 times after that and won at
least once oh geez and this year
greatest female boxer yes
yes
well she's having a celebrity match with
laila ali oh yes that's true yeah and
they still punch like girls that's true
so but yeah let's go on and say that
this is an example of white privileged
culture that louis c.k won a grammy even
though he's a mexican guy hispanic
privilege yes
because heterosexual privilege is not
enough apparently you have to team it up
with something do you have any idea how
hard it is to be a redhead mexican
it's only worked for two people ever
louis ck
and canelo you don't even have to have
mexican in that sentence no just instant
that's true across it's hard enough if
you're a redhead in the royal family
yeah it's it's just not easy
but really there's the two words that
describe everything perfectly is r kelly
yeah like for 20 years everybody just
let that happen yeah so you're not
allowed to say anything right but like
you knew that he urinated on people like
i hate to be that blunt but that's what
happened and by the way when we say
urinated on people we do mean you know
sexual way not like you know at a urinal
and there's like the splatter because he
doesn't have urinal etiquette no we mean
on sex prisoners in his house yes ah
yeah wow then you're like this guy and
his house was more prison than it was
house this yeah this guy had consensual
sex in a way that didn't involve sex
with anyone else but him yes in a room
what didn't suge knight kill people
that's correct he did kind of an award i
don't know that he won grammys but he
showed up at bet yeah he's like anyone
who don't want your producers all up in
the videos he dangled vanilla ice from a
balcony and he did kill he killed people
later tv well he killed people on uh the
uh straight out of compton yeah he just
he just drove he just drove through them
like how was he out was he being was he
furloughed yeah well he puts it in
reverse and without even flinching so
you know he's killed before yes like you
just see it like he's like well this is
something i do usually yes and you're
like this is this the first time he's
been caught because there's a camera
because they're filming a movie right
go to paris yeah and then they wouldn't
show up like oh they would like to go
yeah yeah
right around trial time they they'd like
to take a first class trip to paris in
handcuffs the price is right joke's on
them because they got first class on
spirit right oh they don't go to paris
well and a lot of
i i say this about comedians and a lot
of you know like like you're not
necessarily a role model because you're
an artist right it's just the reality
like there's nothing wrong with honestly
sorry there's nothing wrong with bruno
mars doing cocaine if he's putting out
good music i know that sounds bad he can
win his album but yeah there's great
albums that have been put out on a lot
of drugs all the 70s stuff come on where
do you think he can it's a meritocracy i
mean savvy davis jr married someone uh
just for the the work visa and uh he
couldn't even get to the honeymoon suite
without beating the hell out of her yeah
and you know he didn't win a grammy
because mr bojangle's not all that great
no it wasn't the best work he was it
wasn't his best work but he could dance
he could dance well look if you're going
to i mean his death perception was off
so he'd go off stage every now and then
that's true
i know we've gone over this obviously in
the entertainment industry but go over
to sports let's look there and see if
you apply the same standard where
somebody who commits a crime should no
longer be able to have a job and do
their sport because that's not been
applied right ray lewis killed someone
and was still a linebacker on a super
bowl what did this person deserve yes
well i i mean that's the debate yeah
were they were they filming uh you know
straight out of compton without uh suge
knight's approval that's true i mean
were they dating a waiter
yeah it's unbelievable the amount uh if
you like this person you like that team
what you will put up with right you
would never ever ever in a million years
let that person come to your house if
they were not a star athlete a star
performer in this case or because they
are you're like oh yeah come on man
that's no big or a former vice president
dude yeah right exactly ray rice hit a
woman's was it ray rice
punched his fiancee this isn't yellow oh
yes so hard that it closed the casino do
you have any idea how harsh that's tough
yeah they were like oceans of [ __ ] i
mean i've watched casinos have biker
shootouts and like all right boys it's
the hearty boys like oh you boys come on
this is one where they're like we can't
go in that elevator yeah we can't go in
that elevator they kept gambling addicts
away you know how hard that is yes
yeah i don't need it anymore i'm good
they didn't even let the video poker
continue yeah like unplug that no i am
done all of it anything with poke hurt
anything with her in it it's just it's
not over that's why when uh colin
kaepernick says is it just because i
kneel it's like trust me that's not why
it's not because you suck okay they
allow people who again to reiterate what
dave said hit women so hard it shuts
down casinos they allowed them back into
the league it's just that you are not
good
yes you wanted the nike swoosh and you
couldn't throw to get it yes
which is what you have to do yeah you
know who else took a knee me because
they wouldn't let me play right yep me
too
you all took a knee gerald because he
blew out his knee at notre dame
you know he should have taken a knee
rudy
oh damn it there we go
and by rudy i mean the towel boy
exactly oh yeah well he should have
taken a knee to be scrubbing that floor
with that janitor who taught him all
about life remember that you know the
guy who inspired a movie and is a
multi-millionaire because of it yeah and
every time he's at the university of
notre dame and every time he gives a
motivational speech he's a dick he's
kind of yeah
i'm just like wow i thought rudy was
going to be really grateful because he
was gifted an opportunity that he didn't
deserve turns out he's a real prick yeah
he came to our school and got mad at us
other questions well
he's a persnickety fellow he's not sean
astin at all it's so funny he's that
angry leprechaun but this is the problem
with the industry and again just take
this and sort of shrink it down right
you have this okay uh all of these blue
check marks on twitter right these are
people who are producers they're show
runners some of them are actors some of
them are comedians uh and they want to
make it so that louis c.k can't be
recognized for his work because of you
know his indiscretions and at what point
do we want a culture of forgiveness of
some kind of grace i mean this is a guy
who didn't commit a crime this is a guy
who admitted to it this is a guy who
atoned for his sins and this is a guy
who also happens to be one of the best
comedians of all time at a certain point
do we really want a culture where no one
can ever actually
you know redeem themselves
we don't want any redemption stories
those are some of the most important
stories in life but let's scale it down
what do you have you have that like i
said in comedy clubs that's why dave and
i look
big reason that um i wasn't doing
stand-up two for years is because it's
big enough but didn't have enough of the
resources for security so david we're
not doing comedy clubs that's what we
said you know tulsa oklahoma i think you
can bring it up may 14th
lightweighter.com tour we just go to a
venue and we take care of the rest you
guys show up because no one can cancel
it you don't like it don't show up you
want to see you want to watch a show buy
a ticket go watch the show that's what
but that can't be done for people who
are starting from the bottom now i don't
know how that works unless you play ball
when people at the top
are really sort of applying this kind of
pressure not just to producers not just
to the grammys but to
managers agents bookers right venue
owners it's really concerning well it's
not even just the youtube or twitter
social media or outlets
managers agents all that you just said
it's servers it's people who run
websites saying you can't even have your
own personal website because we're not
going to allow you to have a store here
we're not going to allow you to sell
this stuff on like us shopify shopify
shopify vandas the ladder with crowder
shop they didn't even give us a reason
yeah and then you just said we don't
we're just going to get ready we're like
well why we're on don't tell the social
amazon amazon web services they will
kick you off as well so every single
company they're taking away every
possibility that you have to make a
living other than getting back out on
the road and hoping a club manager will
let you perform even though you're a
superstar and i'm not saying it to be
martyr you can go buy the merch we were
just we were very surprised i was like
well it's like two days hey shop if i
decided to uh to kick you off i said
you're bullshitting it doesn't make any
sense they were like well we don't like
uh the shirts but where do you start at
the bottom that's a good question if we
both started in what i was 20 you were
around there i was seven well i was 12 i
started acting i was 17 18 when i
started doing stand up so like if you
were born at that time i guess it would
be what two thousand whatever four yeah
to just say i'm not a mathematician
it'll be two thousand i'm not probably
2005 2006 yeah yeah who would you even
look up to like would you even want to
do it right i can't imagine who you
would like i looked up to people like
depaulo who was here the other day like
people that were extremely edgy i can't
imagine who you would look up to now
well you can do the fake edgy you know
you can do the amy schumer you know like
your vagina smells like a barnyard
animal people go ooh she's brave or
nanette but if you actually say
something disgusting that's a sacred cow
like you can't say you can't say that uh
that biological males are not that they
can't menstruate
what
you saw that ad too huh yeah they're
selling
there are tampons where they're selling
tampons for giant fat transgenders like
what are you selling a climbing rope
yeah i thought there was a tampon
commercial where a kid was having his
first period a boy but i guess it was a
joke but now i'm still not sure well
i've heard things i'm only sure about
one thing
after that comment you'll never win a
grammy now oh no moving on
what am i gonna do
not be a pretentious jerk
you're totally safe i don't even know
like that's ex well nate pargotti was up
for one white privilege i mean it's
unbelievable i know just all these white
men it's not you can't find if you look
at the top grossing comedians of all
time nary a black man to be found
i don't even know who i would name right
now it would be kevin hart yeah uh and
then of course all time would probably
have dave chappelle you'd have all time
as far as recognize it the best you
would have richard pryor eddie murphy
eddie murphy was definitely a top
grossing comedian for a long long time i
mean look it's one of those things if
you're funny you're f it used to be if
you're funny or funny now they
well they try and cancel you or they
actually physically slap you will smith
think about that that was a physical
manifestation of what the left wants the
left wants to cancel louis c.k and what
i mean by that is they want to remove
his ability to be recognized for his
talent for his art with a grammy and
then if you tell a joke that they really
don't like they also justify physically
slapping you because they say that words
are violence too also should you choose
to not use your words silences violence
so you know what screw you we'll say
whatever we want and uh if you want to
try and come slap us we got something
for you yes and by that i mean security
with guns turn up the other cheek is
that is that what you meant like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah turn
it turn the other cheek yeah because by
that i mean i'll turn their cheek around
their head like the exorcist
okay
smash that like button by the way if
you're on youtube that helps with the
algorithm and uh it also really grinds
stephen colbert's gears
it really grinds
speaking of non-media
that's non-comedy get it non-midi it's
not as good as claptor but i'm trying to
make it a thing so
they shouldn't be i don't think clapture
counts when they have to hit a button
right yes because it doesn't even take
the effort to get people to like the pan
ring doesn't even work no they have to
be like clap well they actually do they
shot collars now they're like put this
collar on for it and they zap you if you
don't the crowd animator when you think
about stephen colbert the crowd animator
who has to tell the left he had less
work to do on the set of according to
jim yeah
i don't know if that's
true it's about and that show is about
as entertaining as chlamydia well well
comedians at least you enjoyed getting
it at least it makes you feel something
burns so
let's go to the border let's go south to
the border hey where louis c.k is from
oh there you go you know white
revolution there you go louis c.k just
claim you're seeking asylum
done
yeah i'm seeking asylum yes so screw you
they won't know what to do like i don't
what's worse
i don't know how the hierarchy i don't
know how to think their heads just
explode so what will people like me more
for
or what will they hate me the least
amount for yeah i don't know anymore i
should just kill myself oh
of course i would never advocate that no
ever ever ever though there is a special
i think that we're running at crowder
shop on shotgun tow triggers i'm just so
yeah just saying i mean if you got a toe
we also have a pre-tied noose yeah
that's pretty good mm-hmm we also have
to take the guesswork out of it for you
we have bottle of pills
it's just a roller derby this is true we
have a wrist opener
yep we do have a nice wrist open i don't
know it's like a can opener but it's you
don't use it on a camera we have one
that's really nice it's like the
pinterest wrist opener that you put on
the wall next to the fridge so it's just
it's just always there have like some
pithy comment
we have a private meet and greet with
courtney love yes little snarky
we also have uh we also have uh you can
do a ride along with suge knight
no walk along he rides you walk yeah
well it's more of a pickup you stand on
the corner he picks you up now uh friday
let's go south of the border here friday
former vice president joe biden right
the administration i guess i should say
announced that it would be uh ending
pandemic related restrictions on
immigration ah so let me uh explain to
you what this means there was something
called title 42 okay under that policy
uh border officials could uh get rid of
they could expel they could deport
illegal immigrants uh predicament of
public health grounds right now
i'm not saying
that kovid should change
our immigration policy i think it should
remain relatively stable and that you
sign the guest book yeah
that's it that's the policy just that's
the policy and the policy revolving door
back right yeah exactly
so or really where you came out they
jump over the wall and they land in the
trebuchet that just yeah so that's my
belief that being said it would be hard
for the left it would be hard to say to
try and make the claim that it's a
tenable position that covet happened
and so you weren't going to shut down
the border based on public health
grounds right it would be very hard to
say this is the worst pandemic that
we've ever seen we're going to shut down
your business
we're going to shut down your ability to
make a living
but we're not going to do anything about
people coming in uh coming to the border
uh you know untested we have no idea so
in other words this would have been
appropriate for the left now
they're ending that on the public health
grounds they're saying we're not going
to do that anymore because that's them
saying covet is no longer a thing so
when you see someone wearing a mask
alone walking down a sidewalk after your
belly laugh be sure to let them know
that this administration has said that's
not a thing anymore
you don't have to i was at wrestlemania
this weekend and when i just saw people
in mask it's like what are you doing
like if you're gonna get coveted it's
here stop
do you smell these fans
like it's
just
you're not you're not you're helping
someone trying to keep making crocs a
thing it's like it's not going to be a
thing no it's just you it's just a
family it's just you stelter and i don't
use that word very often no it is
offensive so they're gonna they're going
to stop enforcing this under title 42.
okay so border arrivals is a nice term
expected to go from 5.9 000 about per
day to 18 000. oh so that's more per day
yeah
it's a multiple it's because they have
cnn down there and they're like all
right gates are open boys exactly let's
head north we got votins over here yeah
well that's about what we're what we're
going to get to and this is important as
we're dealing with ukraine russia right
where people are talking about a
nation's right to be sovereign right
ukraine united states let's not talk
about that so under uh president donald
trump uh unauthorized the
illegal immigration numbers they dipped
to a 10-year low okay a 10-year low
now when we say we're no longer going to
enforce this and we're going to triple
the numbers uh based on not uh you know
uh implementing the policies of title
42. uh who do you think this is going to
affect well it's not going to affect joe
biden just like increasing taxes only on
those people making more than 400
thousand a year how much does a
president make four hundred thousand a
year got it i thought you picked that a
thin air this isn't going to affect them
it's going to affect mainly those living
in border states and guess what
the plebes aren't too happy the
announcement title 42 will end in may
has many like governor ducey fearing
that number will jump tenfold it's
something that americans don't think
that we should have an open borders
policy and that is the policy of the
biden administration and all they do is
make it more wide open both of arizona
senators say ending title 42 without a
plan puts arizona communities and
migrants at risk
senator cinema was in yuma recently
where she received the latest update on
what she refers to as the border crisis
now keep in mind some of that footage
was from arizona
yeah
now a swing state we'll get back to that
so joe biden former vice president joe
biden wants to make every state a border
state let me give you some some all
references available at
lotterathcrowder.com so last year the
new york post
uh you know frequently banned by twitter
for breaking stories that are accurate
like hunter biden yeah yeah uh they
reported that by administration
was supposedly flying underage
immigrants uh from texas to places like
jacksonville and
westchester new york that's a good place
yeah well it doesn't make sense you're
why west chester new york well now it
appears that these flights to new york
they've continued they've started back
up and also places like houston oklahoma
city by the way we'll be in tulsa may
14th
um this all comes right now on the back
of a record number a record number of
what they classify as border encounters
so in 2019 it was 977 000. uh we're not
including the 2020 numbers because
things were just obviously very
different they dipped because of the
pandemic 2021 1.7 million that's almost
a double that's first year of joe yeah
and just in 2022 when they last
registered the numbers 836 000 and
that's what them having been lowered and
now those numbers are going to be
tripling on a daily basis okay so under
under former vice president biden about
2 million illegal immigrants
have entered the country the estimates
are seven million by midterms now i know
i know i know that you know the
democrats are going to try and gain some
traction here because they want you to
go like hey look the house just passed
legalizing weed and you're like oh i'm
gonna vote for them seven million
seven million illegal immigrants by
midterms still no id required in most
states to uh vote is that what the
democrats want stop with your aryan
brotherhood racist [ __ ] i know it's
unbelievable you're crying out loud i
already i'm tired of handing out
pamphlets all over the office and stop
showing your chess tattoo to uh elliot
goulding yeah he's really upset yeah
that means by the way by the 2024
election if you continue this rate that
would be 20 million
20 million again if they had their way
if there were no checks and balances
that would be a six percent population
increase
a six percent population increase keep
in mind a lot of these swing states
even nevada that wouldn't have been
considered a swing state certainly
arizona significantly less than six
percent of the population you're talking
about a margin of sometimes one percent
when it relates to the voter you're
talking maybe half a percentage point
that is a 20 million
consider that the most popular president
of all time the media tells you that he
has received 80 something million votes
20 million would be significant in that
number and of course these people are
going there you're buying votes 20
million people yeah you bring them in
and of course then it's like well you
know you can just stay can i vote well i
don't know we don't want to have id
because that would be racist and black
people like you bullshitting because
they all want voter id we've given you
those statistics right and and the left
right now is saying oh you're not
allowing asylum seekers because what
this rule did is said we don't care why
you're coming right now because of the
pandemic we're not allowing you to come
in right what you do when you request
asylum is you are supposed to be there
until that decision is made whether it's
for or against you know what they do
right now they catch and they release
yes right 1.5 million as of now waiting
that's four to six years until you get a
phone call that says okay your hearing's
ready you know how many people actually
show up not a whole lot yeah not a whole
lot in the car oh i moved i didn't get
the notice i'm so sorry right
a number so i changed my gender
yeah that's not me i won that was carlos
i am uh i am carla now and that person
has a penis and i don't so don't
detonate me i'm going to vote i'm
juanita
i'm anita and i had the sex with arnold
schwarzenegger yes it did is
it's a big mexican terminator baby
that's it scream your period so it's
about to get a lot worse what can we
expect from a man
who said this about immigration we
should not be locking people up we
should be making sure we change the
circumstance as we did why who built the
cage's job
and those who come seeking asylum we
should immediately have the capacity to
absorb them keep them safe until they
can be heard
if you wish to answer should someone who
is here without documents and that is
his only
offense that's crime should that person
be deported that person should not be
the focus of deportation we should
fundamentally change the way we deal
with things a couple of things by the
way they don't believe in deporting
illegal immigrants who are in our
prisons
just so you understand sanctuary cities
sanctuary cities so that you're taking
trump
that your tax money goes to
something about i don't remember i think
at some point there was something about
taxation without representation at what
point do you feel like you no longer
have a voice with this government i
can't imagine there's a significant
amount of americans who are paying these
people's salary who say like yeah well
we should keep the we should overcrowd
our prisons with illegal immigrants
because we don't want to be cruel
let's keep them here so again don't let
them just try and use that example where
they say no we shouldn't deport them
that's their only crime but they don't
believe in deporting people if they
commit more crimes that's the leftist
policy even worse than that now
democrats strongly supported hr one was
the for the people act which again
included automatic voter registration ah
20 million additional 20 million of
dishes
we have this from congress.gov automatic
registration means a system that
registers an individual vote in
elections for federal office in a state
by electronically transferring the
information necessary unless the
individual affirmatively declines to be
registered the individual will be
registered to vote in such elections but
yeah by the way do you know one it's
illegal if you're not a citizen of this
country to be able to do it they don't
care no but that was the that was what
they said they said no they won't do it
it's illegal gerald and i'm like they're
here illegally yeah they've told you on
their resume i will break the law yes
who are they registered to vote for uh
who whoever is handing out the most
candy isn't that right yeah well because
a lot of them are conservative they
would be to be honest yes yeah they'd be
more conservative but the problem is
they don't necessarily understand the
parties at this point but do they check
a box and they're like just you know if
you want us to change this let us know
right pretty much yeah yeah you're
voting all democrat right yeah right you
like a voting machine it has facial
recognition software for latino and if
it tries to go to the republican box
it's like playing
they're pong a b and then what they're
like c you heard him he said yes yes yes
he said it's an affirmative response yes
good check it yeah they're gonna they're
not gonna they're going to not vote
because it's illegal by the way it
doesn't even allow it doesn't require a
proactive act of illegality as opposed
to you know
crossing the border right going having a
coyote transport your family i think
that these people at this point they're
going to break all these laws together i
understand because they want to come to
the greatest country that's ever existed
believe me i get it our country is
better than mexico mexico sucks that's
why they want to leave however that
doesn't mean that we have to accept
everybody you think they're going to go
through all of those proactive steps of
crime only to then have to proactively
not commit a crime and say by the way
don't uh i don't want to be registered
to vote because i am here against the
law
well
yeah yeah the law basically requires you
to
be registered to vote or out yourself
yes
it's the worst sting operation
if the government just allows the men
it's going to just completely [ __ ] my
coyote business yeah well that's true
well you shouldn't be dancing on the bar
tops
i'm ugly they're actually saying that
coyote so i'm hot
no you're not that was absolutely
terrible they're actually saying that
the drug the cartels they're so
sophisticated they will just tell people
to claim asylum knowing that they'll get
released right now four to six years for
that that trial to come up yeah the
hearing it will be a decade once you
start flooding the system with more
people and guess who that hurts the
video that we saw just a second ago it
always hits me when kids are in those
situations in war or anything like that
guess who that hurts those families
because they can't come here legally
because of this problem exactly
understand what this does to the system
it hurts people who are trying to come
here legally yeah we can know a certain
point we have to close the books and say
look we have to deal we have to process
the people who we have here we don't
really even know who's here and by the
way you know who else is going to hurt
when you have people coming into this
country and again just think of the law
hr one right where they would have to
proactively say no no we actually don't
want to be registered to vote these
people of course many people who come
here illegally they get to benefit from
from government services they get to be
they get to use our emergency rooms and
since there's no social security number
they just go use the emergency rooms as
though it's a general practitioner leave
never pay a bill that's funded by your
tax dollars they get to often use ebt
card benefits welfare benefits not all
them but there are ways around the
system and you now have record high
inflation you have food shortages in the
store and then people who have no dog in
the fight who aren't paying taxes who
are here illegally that's a problem for
everybody here so understand this when
you vote hr1 automatically registers
people and of course former vice
president biden
he not only approved he celebrated the
passage here's him actually a statement
he said i applaud speaker pelosi in the
house of representatives for passing h.r
one and the for the people act of 2021
so they want to say it's the for the
people some people they try and say well
this isn't really going to have the
illegal immigrants vote you know
although we're against voter id and by
the way you're automatically registered
to vote you're automatically registered
to vote if you're here illegally and
there's no they don't want voter id
that's it case closed they want illegal
voting of course but here's new york
city councilman uh mr rodriguez uh
saying the quiet part out loud a lot of
people running for city office
they don't spend time in those
communities
because they see those people
as secretary class citizens
they deserve 20 boys
we used to allow new yorkers that when a
citizen support 150 years ago
and we started changing
when new immigrants were coming we've
made progress irish they were italian
they were jewish
and for me
it's important everyone to recognize
this bill will not delude the power of
anyone by the way a couple of things
there first off not all the irish and
italians were coming here illegally
right they were coming off the boat and
they were immediately being processed
right they weren't trying to evade uh
the authorities in this country second
believe they were treated as
second-class citizens yes i believe they
had to deal with some kind of
persecution the irish and italians i
believe were treated the worst if i
recall absolutely and here's the thing
though even when you look back
the irish mob compared to ms-13 at
positively quaint they wouldn't be able
to
what
you're telling me you cut off his head
gouged out his eyes and put it on a
turtle and then sent it to the family in
the mail you overnighted it we were just
gonna
we just cut you a little bit i mean we
would have we would have stopped before
the turtle yeah we would have stopped
before the turtle like guys i appreciate
it i appreciate we do it after you're
dead i mean we're not animals but wait a
second you mean to say that you're
trafficking children across the border
and i i want to understand that teardrop
tattoo there that's you advertising all
your crimes hey layla a bit that's an
admission of guilt
what is wrong with you like even the ira
when they would claim credit you know
they'd they'd stay anonymous you're just
telling people
this might as well be a a tattoo that
reads take me to prison no yes no it
makes no sense always crying so here's
here's the big issue they want of course
our borders open because it's cruel to
not allow our borders to be open uh i
think that it's cruel to actually put
people into like you said these
situations where it ends up separating
families where it puts people into us
and it ends up hurting people who
actually want to be here legally who
deserve to be here legally who've worked
to actually get their their place in the
queue but
i under okay
if this were consistent
or if the left would say okay well look
this is that we don't believe in any
kind of borders we believe in
international governments we don't want
a wall all right got it however uh
haven't we heard them um
make the argument about sovereignty and
about people being able to protect their
own country it seems like this was the
story in the news after covet and now
cove is not a thing
about the do we have a clip that's why
president biden asked me to come here to
underscore our steadfast commitment to
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity sovereignty and it's why we
will continue our relentless diplomatic
efforts
to prevent renewed aggression
and to promote dialogue and peace let me
start by first saying a few words about
russia and ukraine
i've been absolutely clear with
president putin he has no
misunderstanding if any
any assembled russian units move across
ukrainian border that is an invasion
said that word again border but it will
be met with severe and coordinated
economic response that i've discussed in
detail with our allies as well as laid
out it works so well clearly for
president by the way don't you love how
he took his mask after he sat down and
started screaming he's like you could
have just walked out without a mask it's
all political theater it is at this
point hey what's a border
if they assemble troops at the border
what is a border this is to change my
mind right the socratic method just ask
someone what's a border
and then apply it consistently they
can't do it it's a completely untenable
position just like with gender we have
another one coming up next monday i
changed my mind with several different
students it's what's gender so gender
what's sex and they say well sex and
gender are different because sex is
biological and gender is a societal
construct there's a very new argument
but it's untenable because you go okay
are sports separated by societal
constructs
or biology
it's not a tenable position what's a
border if you apply it to the ukraine
you have to apply it here so
uh march 11th former vice president
biden signed a
13.9 billion dollar aid package six for
the 13 points 13.6 well i don't know i'm
dyslexic
my nines look like sixes
i do the same yeah i was writing upside
down i 66 the girl yeah me too that's
86. yeah but that's because she was
gonna talk to the fuzz
i hit it with my 187 teslas
you know that model's coming out so uh
13.6 billion dollars uh-huh to you and
paid to ukraine for border security it's
in border security roughly by his own
words yeah at the same time decreasing
funding for our own border patrol by 428
million dollars in 2021 oh come on oh
good how are the mass graves in ukraine
doing by the way yeah really good he's
doing fantastic work
also canceled funding for the wall uh of
course and in a february letter to
congress he wrote i have determined that
the declaration of a national emergency
at our southern border was unwarranted
i also well by the way you said
emergency okay i also have announced
that it shall be the policy of my
administration that no i'm sorry i
misspelled of kamala harris's
administration that no more american
taxpayer dollars be diverted to
construct a border wall that's right no
no we should spend billions billions
billions protecting the border of
countries halfway across the globe
while uh of course uh leaving ours wide
open because there's no credit we
shouldn't we shouldn't worry about this
we don't need to have borders here we're
a country imagine no borders imagine no
countries again imagine nothing to live
nothing to kill or die for that means
nothing to live for and guess what
nationalism is pretty damn good i don't
mean ethnonationalism being proud of
your country is a pretty damn good thing
you've never had peace exist in this
world through some kind of an
international globalization or treaty
because guess what happens someone
eventually breaks it so your best bet is
to be a nationalist
with the best country with the country
and i'm not saying that america is
perfect with the country that does the
least amount of damage with the country
that does the most amount of good but
it's pretty tough to do that or to
identify that country if you don't
believe in defining countries that
requires a border
ukraine's a country well they yeah
united states it's just a you know it's
just a it's more uh
conceptual well don't worry we're
considering giving them another 500
million dollars i just found out where
they got it from the border patrol yes
yes there you go so yeah
i see how that works now thanks joe
someone's head on a turtle in el paso i
was like thanks great job joe i really
appreciate it
in brooklyn yeah
yes in westchester
westchester is like what what did we
there's just some guy in westchester
who's like they took my times charlie
why joe money no i was waiting for a bus
i could never open a ketchup oh my gosh
challenge
name that movie line for people who
haven't watched
movies
uh comment below name that movie line
whoever wins it wins a lock of gerald's
lower back hair
by that i mean
upper thigh hair i'm in that general
region uh
smash the like button we're gonna play
steven knows sports on mug club right
now and talk about this a little more in
a way we can't talk about on youtube
youtube you can piss off
[Music]